every night before I go to sleep I wind
down with some Infowars I was shaken to
my core to hear a dark story of pure
evil of demonic creatures that were
coming for our children we got footage
this weekend most shocking I've ever
seen period of a drag queen festival and
they show up and they have their way
with your children and demon offense
high on the demon be inclusive don't be
mean to me don't get lost in the
subtlety here he's warning us about a
very real threat there are demons
reading manifestos about diversity and
inclusion to our kids and it's happening
all over the nation Alex Jones has been
sending his reporter Millenial Milly
aka rainbow snatch to go deep undercover
to totally public drag queen events you
cross the line when you start dragging
children into the middle of it this is
obviously mature content yeah obviously
these events are still happening and I
found one in Denver Colorado
I'm gonna go undercover and I'm gonna
expose these satanic creatures
it's a girl multicolored coots
okay I'm going in I'm really scared
do you think they're just gonna attack
me as soon as I walk in I'm risking my
life to get the truth for you oh it's
just my undercover camera I mean if not
I don't know is nothing you can bring
those guys into hey guys so you good
thing you come in okay so I don't have
to go undercover and the woman who owns
the bookstore is like really welcoming
and sweet but this is just a cover-up
for the secret nefarious workings of
drag queen storytime the demons
themselves I'm Shirley and this is my
friend
Dixie so this book is called the boy who
cried what on earth were these parents
thinking what they're showing kids that
they can do is that they can be whoever
they want to be it's nice to see that
there's more to this world than just
people that look like him did you bring
Olivia here by choice or did you make a
deal with a witch and so now you're
cursed to come here by choice very much
my choice right I know that you're
supposed to say about choice because
they looking at it we like bringing in
her all different story hours all these
books have different themes to them not
every princess lives in a castle not
every fairy has now how old is Olivia 10
months 10 months that is young to start
them on inclusivity don't you think I
think not
bringing under direct mid-story hours to
respect the differences in people do you
worry that if your kids are watching the
story hour that maybe in 20 years
they'll come to you and say like mom and
dad I want to be a drag queen high five
kids be who you want to be this is
making me real uncomfortable it's time
to confront this pure evil head-on
before we get started just give me one
second
I bind me demons from doing harm now I
am fully protected and we can go ahead
and talk some of our critics in the
media landscape have suggested that you
are gobbling demons what do you have to
say about that I mean I think using the
fear to say that where some goblin
demons is just just that mere what are
you really trying to teach we're just
reading books for kids because we want
them to feel loved and valued and
included and if they feel those things
they will help other people feel those
things I mean let's get real don't you
think these kids are too young to hear a
story like red red is such a great story
about a crayon that's blue but in a red
wrapper and all the other crayons think
that it's red try to make the crayon
draw red things and I think they're
boots don't make sense and why are they
dressed like this I mean we are just
absolutely this fabulous this is an art
form make up his own point how do you do
that
imagine if kids learned about inclusion
when they were four or five and they
grew up their entire lives being
welcoming and open to people who were
different from that whatever you did to
your lips I'm gonna need to do that
ricktum they thought they were giving me
a makeover but really I'm using their
tactics against them I'm going to teach
these kids some good conservative values
this book is called Fernanda cook thank
you everybody
if they're all about inclusivity and not
judging people then how come they're
judging me and my judgments of them if
you had something to say to Alex Jones
what would you say to him
I don't know eyes once they shut up see
not inclusive at all